that'd be very difficult because you'd
have to go basically raw to get rid of
all this stuff no you don't okay well
that's good i'll get i'll give i'll give
you an example i'll give you an example
are we in danger of committing the same
sin as sodom and gomorrah find out on
this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live we're glad that you
stopped by today and uh we have a guest
today that is not a stranger to little
light here eric wilson thank you so much
for coming back and blessing us
he's basically family uh we talk all the
time so it's it's awesome to have you
come back on and bless us with yet
another show and uh we welcome you back
well it's a blessing for me to be here
so i'm intrigued by today's topic here
you know obviously holding out an apple
is uh is a bit of are we taking this uh
this sin are we are we are we taking the
lies of the devil what are we going to
talk about today well we're going to
talk about appetite and we're going to
talk about what that word means because
there's a lot more there than most of us
realize
so anyway i hope that this will be a
blessing i know it will for those that
are watching uh so let's let's get
started let's jump in
appetite satan's strongest hold upon
mankind
the bible tells us something in first
corinthians 3 chapter 3 verse 16 and 17
it says know ye not that you are the
temple of god
the word god in greek is theos and it
has two definitions two primary
definitions deity and divinity
we are the temple of deity and divinity
and it says and that the spirit of god
dwells inside of each of us
and then the apostle paul was inspired
to tell us if any man or woman
defiles the temple of god
him shall god destroy for the temple of
god as holy which temple we are
i grew up thinking that's a scary verse
god is gonna
if you if you defile my temple i'm gonna
smash you but that's not what the verse
is saying there's another verse i
believe in hebrews and all through the
old testament in leviticus where it says
our god is a consuming fire
if you take a fire into your hands how
can you hold a fire and not be burned
if god who is a consuming fire dwells
inside of our hearts
how can we have sin inside of us
willfully
and it not be burned
so god is saying
i want you to realize that i'm inside of
you amen it's an amazing thing that the
the body is is such a powerful machine
that you can literally put poison toxin
and junk inside of it and that thing
still works yeah um and i think that
there there a lot of times there's not
an immediate judgment upon what you're
putting in your body so this is kind of
one that i think that we need to to
really dive in and it it and and
understand so i'm excited that you're
bringing this topic up because uh it's
not an easy one
it it's not but this touches every
single person i don't care if they're a
church-goer if they're not if they're an
atheist if they're a buddhist it doesn't
matter who you are
this will speak to you
i'm going to show you something this is
a time magazine article special health
issue it says
our super-sized kids y'all remember that
movie a number of years ago super size
me he changed the menu that mcdonald's
had that's power yeah yeah and i think
like mcdonald's has seen an uptick in in
sales ever since it first started right
it's always increasing and when that
documentary came out i think he took it
down by three percent the first time it
ever like dipped which is power that is
america and many of the cultures in our
modern world today are witnessing an
unforeseen epidemic
one that is terrifying in its nature in
the and in man's apparent inability to
bring it under control
we have sown in self-indulgence and the
consequences we are sure to reap i want
to show you a couple of articles that
really caught my attention
we would like to thank all of you who
support this ministry through your
donations and by buying merch from
lightwear.shop
we cannot do this without you and if you
send in your pictures we will put you on
the show
and i want you to i want you
really focus on this because like on
this time magazine they're showing
childhood obesity
and that's a big issue right now
but i want you don't be limited in your
mind to thinking appetite and obesity
because we're going to show there's
something there that many of us have not
realized
this is from cnn news their health
program
it says the current state of childhood
obesity in america
they showed that according to
2016 and 2017 data
mississippi was rated as being the
highest percentage of childhood obesity
they were at 26.1 percent wow
of the children that live in mississippi
are obese
that's terrifying and i'm not judging
mississippi but this is where we're at
show you another one this one really
caught my attention you can find this
all over the news for the last 10 years
this is from a website called task and
purpose they're a military website
and you can find this on news from
from the military themselves from the
army from the navy
they said
the department of defense is a microcosm
of our nation
we recruit from the nation
the director of health promotions and
wellness at the army public health
center said
she told
the new york times so the nation's
problems are ours as well if the nation
is becoming obese the military is saying
this affects us
admittedly the military's proverbial
belt has gotten tighter as the obesity
rate has increased steadily in recent
years
the 2018 report found that
17.4 of service members were now
classified as obese wow you don't really
think about that in the military well
i when i saw this i was like you've got
to be kidding me i started doing
research on the military and for the
last 10 years they were saying this is a
huge issue
they were actually and they had i don't
remember where it was from but they had
a recent news release and they talked
about the fact that
the u.s military said we've got concerns
that if the united states had to go to
war again we would be in trouble because
we can't recruit people because they
can't they can't even go through basic
training wow
and i was like well my grandfather was
in the military i mean you know it was
gung ho i mean you got to be like clint
eastwood you've got to be able to do 100
push-ups and
it's not that way anymore
so i think that speaks to the priorities
of the country i was just watching a
video on youtube and this woman was
going through an article of a list of 30
or 31 foods that are banned in
international countries but are still
allowed in the united states
skittles and these other things just
because these colors these artificial
flavors amen they impact the body even
causing cancer and um
she was saying when you look at the
healthcare system of the united states
most of these other countries a lot of
these international countries actually
pay
for um
the
the health care of their citizens yeah
but the united states doesn't fit the
bill for people who are sick so not only
is the economy growing because people
are buying the foods when they get sick
and go to the hospital they're still
having to pay for their own health care
whereas these other countries they're
like man we don't want to pay for all
these sick people so let's just be more
cautious about what we allow in our
country and provide our citizens to eat
same with their military i bet they want
to keep their citizens healthy yeah sure
it might be for the reason of not
wanting to pay but still it's like it's
good for for the citizens as well so if
the us would hopefully get his
priorities right yeah to help keep the
society healthy i think it's fascinating
it all comes down to money it always
comes out of money and jesus said that
too he said you can either serve mammon
or you can serve me right and so it's it
comes down to what you're gonna i mean
granted i don't think i want
my hospital run like the dmv but
i think that it's fascinating that it's
always pointing back to money
is the primary motivator for everything
in this world right right yeah you don't
care if it's harming people but you're
gonna put that product out there because
it's cheap and lots of people are gonna
buy it and you know many people are
going to get addicted to it and
yeah there's no sort of like you know
man this is really harming my fellow man
like you know yeah we should have
regulations on that but we're not going
to go there
let me show you this other one this is
from the centers for disease control and
this uh in this article they showed that
the percentage of adults in the united
states of america aged 20 and over with
obesity
was
and a half percent from 2017 to 2018.
42 percent
of americans over 20 years old are obese
are classified as obese
this is what got scarier the percentage
that included obesity and overweight in
america between 2017-2018 was 73.6
percent i believe it that's terrifying
oh yeah now
that being said
what we are sharing in this this message
today is not just about obesity
that's what people think about when they
think about appetite being a problem fat
or obese that's not the issue
there's a bigger issue and that's what i
want to show
this is a quote out of a powerful book
called councils on diets and foods page
the controlling power of appetite will
prove the ruin of thousands
for if they had conquered on this point
they would have had the moral power to
gain the victory over every other
temptation
but those who are slave to appetite will
fail a perfecting christian character
the continual transgression of the laws
of god by man for over 6 000 years has
brought sickness pain and death as its
fruit
and as we draw near the close of time
satan's temptations to indulge appetite
will be more powerful and more difficult
to resist
i mean you you've got to wonder
if satan has had thousands of years to
study man's reaction to anything right
by the time he goes to
to try and attempt to get jesus to sin
the first go-to temptation is the sin of
eating something you know like or you
know using food as that temptation uh
you got to think there's something
powerful there yeah there's something
more than what we realize and i don't
know if you're gonna have an answer for
this but i see that every single day we
have these little tiny choices that we
make and if we're making you know bad
choices that we know are harmful to our
bodies
then all those little choices are
basically conditioning you
to basically make the wrong choice and
when something big comes you're not
going to make the right it's almost like
creeping compromise if i compromise a
little bit the next step becomes easier
and pretty soon i'm so far off the path
i don't even know
where the path is anymore yeah that's
why i think fasting is so powerful is
it's you going no no no you're not in
control
you know my body's not in control my
mind is in control yeah
i know go ahead appetite takes different
forms it's not just food i think all
three uh temptations dealt with appetite
one was with food the other one was with
pride yes and then the third was with
worship you know so um just broadening
our perspective don't think that hey i
don't have an issue with food it's
actually good to go right right right
good point and we're gonna get there but
that that's exactly what what we want
people to see
the scripture says
know ye not that your body is the temple
of the holy spirit which is in you this
is in first corinthians 6 19. which we
have of god and we are not our own
i mean like when i sit down to eat
i'm putting
i can never imagine jesus sitting down
and eating after he got done with his
disciples he pushed his back from the
table he's like oh i ain't too much my
belly hurts you know
yeah
you you would never see jesus do that
right
but yet i found myself doing that even
as a christian and thinking it's
okay it says for for we have been bought
with a price even the precious blood of
christ
therefore glorify god in your body and
in your mind
which is god's i've had a lot of
christians that tell me well it doesn't
matter what you do in your body it's god
looks at the heart
well out of the heart are the issues of
our life
what's in your heart manifest in your
lifestyle
yeah the new testament idea of like you
know god
uh
said that everything is is okay to eat
at this point you're right you know and
and it's like you know even paul brings
out the concept that yeah you can do
whatever you want to do but not
everything is profitable to you
and so you know it's like i think
there's a there's a different connection
there that i think people are reading
into that statement i do too
wait he said say it again you said that
the new testament says you can eat
whatever you want well i mean that a lot
of people in the new testament
kind of christianity will say you know
like everything
yeah everything is made like you know we
can eat anything now and and i think
that you know you if you're going to
take that stance then it wouldn't make
sense that he would say hey look not
everything is is going to be beneficial
to you and i think there are certain
things that are definitely not
beneficial to us
the old testament says don't eat pork
but we know of the new testament i mean
just looking at the scientific evidence
of what's inside of the pork
i mean you've seen the facebook videos
right where you see the little bugs
crawling around and worms and stuff like
that so we know it's not just
necessarily a spiritual thing as much as
it was advice to keep our our bodies
healthy yeah and and what who is it that
has that dream peter peter and peter
even interprets that later on and says
hey look this is talking about gentiles
i was talking about food and yeah just
completely missed that part yeah so i
think that's really fast i'm glad you
brought that out
i threw that out there but yeah i
shouldn't assume everybody's like you
know on that same
here's another quote you know speaking
about the our bodies being the temple of
god this is in a book called desire of
ages page 161
it says from eternal ages it was god's
purpose that every one of us
every created being from the bright and
holy seraph or angel to man should be a
temple for the indwelling of the creator
but because of sin humanity ceased to be
a temple for god
darkened and defiled by evil the heart
of man no longer revealed the glory of
the divine one
the bible says that three times in the
new testament first corinthians three
first corinthians six second corinthians
six it says three times in the new
testament we are the temple of god
if god says something three times he's
really trying to get our attention he
wants us to realize that
then it goes on and we're told satan has
made it his study
to lay the temple of god in ruins
to obliterate the image of god of
divinity in man
and by yielding to sin men have become
defiled and corrupted
through sin the temple of god which god
had builded for his own indwelling and
glory was reduced to ruin was fallen and
indicated
so that means and and i used i've talked
to you about this before back before i
gave my life to christ i used to drink
probably 200 worth of alcohol a week
when i was drinking i couldn't see what
i looked like but if i saw myself now i
mean you can go by sometimes when you're
driving through rough parts of the
neighborhood in town and you see people
that are homeless or somebody that's
drunk and they're laying there
with a beer bottle and their vomit on
and you look at that and satan is
mocking god he's saying
you made them to be a temple for you
what do you think about your temple
so he's trying to destroy us not just
spiritually but even physically
in order to destroy what god has done
i found this this is an old picture
has appetite become the acceptable sin
it's almost like you know
most christians will say look i know
god's ten commandments are important you
know these still stand but food doesn't
have anything to do with with sin it's
like
but we we avoid or we totally are
blinded to all the verses in scripture
that talk about
what we put into our mouth and into our
body
so this is for a lot of people become
the the acceptable sin
now this is where we're going to change
gears
we look at this picture of this man
who's gorging himself you know he's got
this young man on the right side of the
screen who's you know feeding him the
twinkies or the the little snacks and
then you see his butler over on the left
that's trying to pull his hand back from
getting the glass of wine and
you know they're trying one side is
trying to prevent this man the other
side is trying to yeah enabling him so
we we have a tendency to think about
appetite is obesity or overweight
but appetite is self-indulgence
appetite affects
all kinds of people not just people that
are i've never been overweight i mean
ever in my life but i was in bondage to
appetite for most of my life i have
never been overweight and i would go i'd
go to church and sit down at a church
dinner and eat four plates and go home
and not be able to do anything for the
rest of the day because my belly was so
full what do they say skinny on the
outside fat on the inside
you know so you could look on the
outside fine but how are you
health-wise amen amen
and that that's got a spiritual
application too you can look good on the
outside even that's kind of concerning
like when you go to the doctor and
they're like oh yeah you're you're
average and sure i guess on one side
that's compliment but maybe it really
isn't going back to the statistics that
you were talking about if 73
right yes of the population is either
overweight or obese
what's the average yeah i don't want i
don't want to be overwhelming is not
healthy versus healthy so then when you
start saying that i'm average that i
don't think that's a good thing
i've known people that have type 2
diabetes and they're not overweight
type 2 meaning if i get this right
because i don't i don't know it
completely but type 2 is the kind that
you can prevent depending on what you
eat that's right but they're
self-indulgence i'm not making any
assumptions here but has caused them to
be this way my grandfather had type 2
yeah
so
that that helps each of us to look at
this and say it's not just people that
are overweight this is talking about
each of us
um does god care what time of the day
that i eat does he want me eating at 12
o'clock at night does he want me eating
you know and i'm not saying for people
that work third shift i mean that
changes your schedule but we've got to
ask ourselves that
and this is funny because you see this
lady gorging herself it's probably
nighttime
and then this is always what happens
afterward
always and we're going to do another
program maybe it'll be the next one
that's going to deal with the science
and sorcery of appetite we're going to
show why people get addicted we're not
going to go there on this one
but
this is what happens
this is this is the same result as
somebody that does cocaine or heroin or
some drug they want it they can't resist
the temptation they yield to it and then
afterward there is this guilt
same thing with with immorality or
sexual sin
or sometimes someone's like oh
uh it's fine because i don't feel those
things but the body always reacts you
know the body doesn't have emotion so to
speak just like i'm tired you're like oh
i'm starting to ache you know yeah so
that coupled with sometimes
that's a good
point listen to this statement this was
written
by a lady in 1914
she said one of the strongest
temptations that man has to meet comes
upon the point of appetite
in all ages temptations appealing to the
physical nature have been most effectual
in corrupting and degrading mankind
through intemperance
satan works to destroy the mental and
moral powers that god gave man as a
priceless endowment
so intemperance
leads to
not being able to have the mental and
moral power to fight spiritual battles
to intercede for my family can you
explain in temperance
yes yes we'll get there okay we're going
to get there
a lack of self-control
in all things
a lack of of
it's kind of like you see a lady at the
walmart or a man at the walmart normally
it's the mother and she's got a
screaming two-year-old in the buggy
that's pitching a fit because it wants
the toy or it wants the candy and rather
than the mother disciplining the child i
don't mean beating i'm just saying
bringing the child to the lord in
patience and in love but in firmness she
allows the child just to act like it's
in control
intemperance is allowing the body to
tell the mind what to do instead of the
body being the servant of the mind and
the bible talks about that the body is
supposed to be the servant of the mind
and the bible also says let this mind be
in us which was in christ jesus
so if i am the body of christ and he is
my mind i should be in surrender willing
surrender to him
it says it is impossible for those who
yield to satan to appreciate things of
eternal worth
through
sensual sensual indulgence satan seeks
to blot from every soul
from the soul every trace of likeness to
god sensual does not mean just sexual
sensual means senses
smell taste
the hearing the feeling
so gluttony we're just going to look at
a couple of examples of this
super bowl parties i mean people like to
watch games and they'll sit around and
you can watch you can watch youtube
videos people are just gorging
themselves on pizza and whatever
how about family get togethers how about
holidays like christmas and easter and
halloween thanksgiving thanksgiving do
you know that is the that is the
scariest thing is because we will sit
down and give thanks to god for
everything he's done for us and then
gorge ourselves and you know almost
everybody at thanksgiving they're all on
the couch going oh
i'm so boy
so great
so wonderful to be here and gorge myself
and you know what shocked me i was one
time i was at my grandmother's and all
our family was there and i had just done
that i'm in the living room i'm look
everybody's just sitting around on the
couch and talking and laughing and
everything and two hours later almost
everybody was going back in the kitchen
to get more to eat and you go wait a
minute
your belly is hurting two hours ago
and you're going back into the kitchen
yeah
keep it going yeah
how's that i still confuse how that's
physically possible we're gonna we're
gonna go in our next program on the
science and sorcery we're gonna get into
why but i'm gonna try not to do that yet
and these things in and of themselves
aren't necessarily bad right it's it's
what you get into while you're in these
things that's right
right
you know restaurants all you can eat you
know it's or if they bring you more than
what you normally should be able to eat
and you feel like i gotta clean my plate
well i don't know if it's because
america suffers from obesity that it's
changed our restaurant habits as a
country but you know if you travel
abroad and you go to europe you know you
order something and it's like little
salad
one little baguette and you're like
that's not gonna fill me up
and that's what they're used to yeah you
come to america and it's like you've got
this super-sized plate it's mounded like
this you want the lunch portion or the
dinner party exactly you know and and
it's very interesting just observing
it is an issue that we have in our
problem but also our restaurants cater
to that kind of stuff and also has to
look a certain way of america versus
have you seen those comparison videos of
uh european mcdonald's versus a u.s
mcdonald's oh tell us for uh in europe
for their mcdonald's their fries the
ingredient list is potatoes and salt do
you know what it is for the united
states it's like 15 ingredients and a
lot of it just to make sure that's the
fry is crispy and it's yellow and all
this stuff and you look at the european
fry and it just just looks like you know
homemade fries it's kind of limp and all
that but i'm sure it tastes good yeah
just like wow so not only is it just
you know the portion it also has to look
a certain way but for in order for it to
look a certain way you have to put in
all these preservatives and things and
yeah it's because that's where you said
that because if it has to look a certain
way it's engaging in another sense
so the sense the the smell the way it
looks the way it tastes it indulges
well i'm gonna try my best not to get
into why but we will do that on our next
program um oh just for those who are
fact checking me it's actually three
potatoes salt and oil
also church dinners yeah a lot of
churches have fellowship dinners or
potluck dinners afterwards that's one of
the easiest places to overeat because
there's all that there
and you sort of excuse it because that
church you know god's gonna he'll wink
at this it doesn't matter if i overeat
so this is the question that i've had a
lot of people ask me and that
that i struggled with answering until
christ gave me the victory
is food really a salvation issue
i've had so many christians even in our
own churches
tell me food's not a salvation issue and
you know what the lord brought to my
mind one day when someone said that
what caused adam and eve
to fall and the entire human race to be
lost
[Music]
it was food and it wasn't a pig it
wasn't a bacon double cheeseburger it
wasn't a
a huge heaping mound of ice cream sundae
it was a vegan organic piece of fruit
it was wonderful it was interesting
because that it was symbolic of
obedience so anything
linking to a salvation issue food what
have you it's linked to obedience and
the bible has a lot to say about food so
of course food is a salvation issue but
i want to pause here can you explain
what salvation issue means just because
we have a broad audience watching
some people will ask if something is a
salvation issue is
if i indulge in this will it keep me out
of heaven
but the answer always if can be answered
no it's not you're going to default to
doing that action exactly it's like
we're just human nature is like what is
the least i can get away with to be able
to like make it still in that
what i think is fascinating about this
is what genesis says about how uh about
eve ate the fruit what it all comes down
to is always do i obey my senses or do i
obey what god says because it says in in
genesis 3 here it says when the woman
saw that the fruit of the tree was good
she saw it with her eyes right
and and pleasing to the eye and also
very desirable for gaining wisdom so
desirable hey i want this it's the
desire i have so when the woman saw that
the fruit of the tree was good for food
and pleasing to the eye and also
desirable for gaining wisdom she took
some and ate it and she also gave some
to her husband so it comes down to do we
obey our senses and what we think and
what we desire or do we obey what god
says what we know what we have studied
that's a good poem glad you brought that
out brian
so let's just look at some examples in
scripture where appetite was an issue
the first one we just talked about adam
and eve in the fall of mankind and eden
noah's day
and we're going to show this
sodom and gomorrah that's what you were
talking about you know are we going to
fall temptation to that same
sin of sodom and gomorrah
remember esau
israel when they were lusting after the
flesh pots of egypt
one of the other examples and we're
coming forward in history was daniel
shadrach meshach and abednego
those men denied their senses so that
their minds would be clear so that they
could resist they were stuck in the
middle of the most sensual culture the
world has ever known babylon and they
were christians
how did they not fall to temptation it
was because they had power over a simple
thing as what i eat
so not compromising on that simple thing
gave them strength the other things were
easy temptations to resist
and then you know it's funny because you
brought this out
man fell with adam and eve
the first temptation that came to christ
was appetite
the very first temptation that christ
overcame was the one that adam had
fallen to
another quote from that book counsels on
diets and foods
satan comes to man as he came to christ
with his overpowering temptations to
indulge appetite
the devil well knows his power to
overcome man upon this point
he overcame adam and eve in eden upon
appetite and they lost their blissful
home
what accumulated misery and crime have
filled our world and consequence of the
fall of adam
entire cities have been blotted from the
face of the earth because of the
debasing crimes and revolting iniquity
that made them a blot on the universe
indulgence of appetite was the
foundation of all their sins
wow
by
let me think how to put this
like you were talking about in
temperance candy
i can remember when i was a partier when
i was young like in you know 20 21 we
used to go clubbing you know
i didn't care about dancing but it was a
place to meet girls and you could drink
and club
we knew
that it was easier to get a girl to
give up her inhibitions if you could get
her to drink
well that's in temperance back back in
the 1800s and 1700s they had the whole
temperance movements that were trying to
do the abolition of alcohol
they wanted to get read about many
people in the united states wanted to
make alcohol totally
off limits
but that sin of indulging in temperance
opens the door for the next sin of
yielding to sexual sin
second peter chapter 3 verse 3 through 5
peter says know this also that there
shall come in the last days scoffers
walking or living after their own lust
their own carnal desires and saying
where is the promise of christ coming
for since our fathers fell asleep
all things continue as they were from
the beginning of the creation until now
we hear people saying that all the time
i hear people even in churches say that
we don't know if jesus is coming back
soon i mean it can be another 100 years
or another 500 years
listen to what the lord tells us but
this they willingly are ignorant of
that the world that then was
being overflowed with water the flood
perished
but the heavens and earth which are now
by the same word
are kept in store
reserved unto fire against that day of
judgment and the destruction of ungodly
men so this is telling us
the end is going to come the judgment is
going to come not only are you being
judged but this judgment being poured
out
judgment is poured out on ungodly men
and women now listen to what jesus said
but as in the days of noah so shall also
the coming of the son of man be
for as in the days that were before the
flood candy what's that say
they were eating and drinking marrying
and giving in marriage until the very
day that noah entered into the ark isn't
it funny that jesus starts off and he
says they were eating and drinking and
people say well i mean you've got to eat
to live that's not what it means in
greek
in the greek context it means
self-indulgent gluttony they were
overeating over drinking they were
drinking things that god had forbidden
things that had been you know fermented
alcohol
and they knew not until the flood came
and took them all away so shall also the
coming of the son of man be so jesus
says eating and drinking was the one of
the problems that caused the sins during
the flood
overindulgence
then in luke 17 jesus goes on and says
likewise also
as it was in the days of lot that was
sodom and gomorrah they did eat and
drank they bought they sold they planted
they built it but the same day that lot
and his family went out of sodom it
rained fire and brimstone from heaven
and destroyed them all
even thus shall it be in the day when
the son of man is revealed
noah's day it was eating and drinking
lot's day it was eating and drinking
christ is trying to tell us something
in malachi chapter 3 listen to what it
tells us he says behold i will send my
messenger and the word messenger means
an angel or a message
i will send my messenger and he shall
prepare the way before me and the lord
or the sovereign king whom you are
seeking shall suddenly come
to his temple
remember we are the temple of god and it
says the king is coming
it says he shall suddenly come that word
means unexpectedly
like a thief but who may abide the day
of his coming and who shall stand when
he appeareth for he is like a refiner's
fire
there are christians right now that are
praying for god to pour out the latter
rain of his spirit
do we want christ to come in his
fullness through his spirit and dwell
inside of us
he's like a refiner's fire
in isaiah 13 it says
therefore i will shake the heavens and
the earth shall remove out of her place
in the wrath of the lord of host and in
the day of his anger and i will make a
man more precious than fine gold even a
man than the golden wedge of ophir
and babylon the glory of kingdoms the
beauty of the chaldeans excellency shall
be as when god overthrew sodom and
gomorrah
so here we've heard about the flood
we've heard about sodom and gomorrah and
now isaiah is equating babylon's
destruction to the same thing that
caused sodom and gomorrah's destruction
by fire
and this is the part that you opened
with
people ask about sodom and gomorrah and
they immediately think about
homosexuality or lesbianism or
perversion or pedophilia or whatever but
listen to what it says in ezekiel 16
verse 49 and 50.
behold this was the iniquity of sodom
pride
fullness of bread and abundance of
idleness was in her and her daughters
there was no fear of god in them
yea they were haughty and they committed
abominations before me as if i could not
see them i see so we focus on the
effects but this is the root this is
what led them that's where we go yeah
there you go the fullness of bread is
what led to all the other results that
you just described the foundation yeah
so it's like for me if i go to the
doctor and the doctor says oh you've got
this problem here take this medication
i'm like
just masking the problem yeah i don't
want a band-aid i want to fix the hole
in the boat
so here god is saying look if you want
to get rid of these problems you've got
to get to the root you've got to get the
root out of there
or otherwise the cancer is just going to
keep coming back
if i'm still eating the red number
40 or whatever in the skittles or
eminem's the cancer is not going to go
away
can i read something yes quote from
isaiah that i think is really
interesting this is talking about the
end
after god is is
pronounced he is righteous he is
wonderful and everything's put back to
normal this really really stood out to
me
um
and i'm gonna read three verse three
verses here and the mean man
shall be brought down and the mighty man
shall be humbled and the eyes of the
lofty shall be humbled but the lord of
hosts shall exalt
shall be exalted in judgment and god
that is holy shall be sanctified in
righteousness
then shall the lamb feed after their
manner and the waste places of the fat
ones
shall strangers eat
wow so isn't that interesting it even
says that you know after this whole
thing is put put back together the god
says the fat ones where they were
the strange strangers will eat in this
place because they are no longer here in
bible times
in in back in in the olden days it was
sought to be you you looked wealthy if
you were big in fact now today when you
see the the cover of um you know those
magazines you see when you're checking
out the grocery store right what do you
see as the the womanly figure on the
front of those magazines it's really
skinny it really and we consider that
beautiful
back then they considered
beautiful plump and large because it
meant you had a lot of money and you
were very wealthy and you could afford
to feed yourself god says no that's not
the way amen interesting that is
interesting
that's very interesting
so malachi talked about this messenger
that god was going to send before the
king returns we know that's jesus
in revelation chapter 14 and revelation
18 it talks about there being three
angels that come down from heaven right
before the second coming of jesus
look what it says about the second angel
and this is referenced in revelation 14.
i'm going to read from revelation 18
it says after these things i saw another
angel come down from heaven having great
power and the earth was lightened with
his glory
and he cried mightily with a strong
voice saying
babylon the great is fallen is fallen
for she has become
what's that say candy the habitation of
devils
and the stronghold of every foul spirit
in the cage of every unclean and
hate-filled bird
babylon is full of demons
jerusalem which is god's people are
filled with his spirit
then look what it says for all nations
have drunk of the wine of the wrath of
her what's that say brad foreign
occasion all right that word pay it mark
that down if you're watching this mark
that word down fornication and watch
what the lord shows us
they're they've drunk the wine of the
wrath of her fornication and the kings
of the earth have committed fornication
with her
and the merchants of the earth have
waxed rich through the abundance of her
delicacies
and there's different ways that we can
look at this but since we're focusing on
appetite keep that in mind
and i heard another voice from heaven
saying come out of her my people and
this is not just talking about rome or
someplace in the middle east he's saying
come out from the world
there's two kingdoms babylon and
jerusalem you want to be part of
jerusalem not part of babylon
he says come out of her my people and be
not partakers of her sins and receive
not of her plagues for her sins have
reached unto heaven and god hath
remembered her iniquities
and there followed another angel
revelation 14 says
saying babylon is fallen has fallen that
great city because she made all nations
drink of the wine of the wrath of her
fornication
the word wrath when you look it up in
greek it means to breathe hard or
passion it's like panting after it's
like a dog in heat or a donkey in heat
the wine of her passion of her fornica
she's longing for this fornication
her desires her lust yes that's exactly
right it's not just because i used to
read that the wine of the wrath why does
it say rap what about just the wine of
our fornication but it says the wrath of
her fornication
now look at the word fornication this is
in greek from that text
the greek word is 4202 in strong's
concordance and the greek word is pornea
that's where we actually get the word
pornography
it's from that word and this is what the
word means harlotry or idolatry its root
word is 4203 which means to act the
harlot
to indulge in unlawful lust or carnal
desires
to practice idolatry and that comes from
4204 which is a trumpet an idolater or a
with a strumpet i know
it's it's a flirt
it's almost like a woman that
she maybe she doesn't do it but she
makes you think she wants to she's a
tease yeah sort of thing or a man
yeah yes there's a lot of that goes
around both sides
but the point being here is is that it
says babylon
had made the nation's drink of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication
and when we look at fornication
to indulge an unlawful lust or longing
or desires
to pant after something
hebrews chapter 12 says
follow peace with all men and holiness
holiness
without which no man shall see the lord
that's a that's a strong statement
holiness without which no man or woman
shall see the lord
watching diligently
lest any man fail of the grace of god so
somebody says i can't overcome that
you're failing of the grace of god the
word grace doesn't just mean mercy it
means the divine influence of god upon
your heart that's what the word means in
greek
then it says lest there be any root of
bitterness
the word rebellion and bitterness are
synonymous in the in the hebrew and the
greek
lest there be any root of bitterness
springing up lest there be any
fornicator
or profane person like esau was
who for one morsel of food sold his
birthright
you and i are sons and daughters of god
are we willing to sell our birthright
for one bite of food
esau did
food people will say food is not a
salvation issue it was for him
in first samuel it says
samuel was speaking to the
to king saul and he says hath the lord
as great delight in burnt offerings and
sacrifices as in obeying the voice of
the lord
behold to obey is better than sacrifice
and to hearken than the fat of rams for
rebellion is the sin of witchcraft and
stubbornness
to resist god is iniquity and idolatry
when you look up the word rebellion
that's the hebrew word bitterness
bitterness
so we look at esau and when i first read
this i was thinking esau there's no
mention in the bible of him
committing fornication like immorally
sexually
but god says him choosing his belly
rather than choosing to obey god
was fornication
he tells us that in the old testament he
says you adulterers and adulteresses
why are you cheating on me
you've chosen another
this is first corinthians chapter 6 and
chapter 10. listen to what the lord says
in the new testament
meats for the belly and the belly for
meats and the word meats there is foods
but god shall destroy both it the belly
and them the foods
for the body is not for fornication
but for the lord and the lord for the
body
whether therefore you eat or drink or
whatsoever you do do all to the glory of
god
i mean that's really interesting that
that it
keeps kind of circling around that
concept you know what i mean like like i
don't know you you would think that it
would just be like you know whatever you
do whatever actions you take you know do
that but the fact that it mentions eat
and drink that's a significant part of
who we are that's right you know and
i've had people tell me well as long as
i'm doing it to the glory of god it's
okay and you're like are you bringing
glory to god yeah are you acting
god-like when you eat too much when you
dear lord please bless this food that i
know has got stuff in it that is bad for
me i've gotten to the point in my life
where i can't pray over food if i know
that what's in there is going to destroy
god's temple
because god lives in here he gave me
this jesus had to die on the cross to
give me a life today dear god please
best this red number 40.
and god is thinking
he's not mad but he's just like eric
where's your heart
i'm like esau
luke 17 jesus said remember the kingdom
of god is within you if i won't let
christ who's the word of god reign
inside my heart
he's like don't you remember my kingdom
is inside you who else is on the throne
the apostle paul goes on and he says
but many
live
of whom i've told you often and now tell
you even weeping that they are enemies
of the cross of christ
whose end is destruction and whose god
is their belly
and whose glory is to their shame
remember it says do all to the glory of
god
they say i'm glorifying god
he says they're glorious to their shame
who mind whose affections are on earthly
things rather than eternal
that's interesting sorry i'm still stuck
on red 40. what's wrong with red fourth
one
red number 40 is a food dye that they
know causes cancer yeah really they know
those two which are what's the other one
yellow five i didn't know that i mean
and you think these are just colors but
no they're chemicals that do lead to
cancer and that's in um
skittles even coffee creamers still to
this day yeah yeah
in this country but their skittles and
other states and other mountain dew has
a lot of yellow in other countries and
they just change uh the
the
ingredient so it's still the same color
but it's a different ingredient which
you know red 40 is cheap who cares about
people's health right yeah
i'm sorry no no that's fascinating i
just know i don't know anything about
it's it's interesting that you bring
that up though because my mother's close
friend is actually allergic to a red
forty she can't have anything with
redford wow
and all this other stuff and so i always
i always remembered that and so when you
said redford and i was like
that's what marilyn had wait what's
wrong with red forty she must have one
at the grocery store like reading all
those labels and trying to do you know
what i have found for me
i look at it i say did god make that if
he didn't make it i don't need to eat it
if it's got some name on it that i can't
pronounce it's funny because you can
look at some stuff even from other
countries and you're like well that
that's a real food
but then you can look at some other
stuff that you go somebody came up with
this in a lab i don't want to eat it
you're attacking a lot of veggie meats
right
now know that'd be very difficult
because you'd have to go basically raw
to get rid of all this stuff no you
don't okay well that's good
i'll give you an example i'll give you
an example
and don't anybody get mad at me but just
give you an example i don't eat meat i
gave the meat up when i was
probably 23 24 and i've been a lot
healthier since i did but before that i
ate anything that wouldn't run faster
than me i mean if
i
yeah
anyway
when i first was like making that
transition off of meat i used to buy
some burgers and i'm just going to use
like like a boca burger or something
they've got like the number one
ingredient in it is gluten i mean like
okay that's not the best thing in the
world for me and then it's got all this
other stuff and salt and oil and msg and
msg under 300 different names
well then i found another company called
amy's and i'm not doing a sales pitch
but they make a veggie burger that has
no gluten in it it has no tofu in it it
has all it is is vegetables and i was
like and it's organic
i eat that it tastes even better than
the other one and i'm at least taking
something that hey god made this
fascinating i don't want to eat
something that was developed in a lab i
want to eat something that came off of a
tree or out of the ground or you know
that was meant to be eaten
anyway i don't want to go into that
we're going to we're going to show some
clips um hopefully in our next program
of some food
what they call it food scientists and
what they do to actually make food taste
the way it tastes and when you find out
what they do it's it's shocking
yeah jude chapter 1
it says remember ye the words which were
spoken unto us before by the apostles of
our lord jesus christ how there should
be mockers in the last days who walk or
live according to their own ungodly
desires
these are they who separate themselves
they are sensual
not having the spirit if you look up the
word sensual in webster's it means
gratification of the senses the
indulgence of appetite
fleshly devoted to the pleasures of sins
and appetite voluptuous lewd or carnal
that's our world today
intemperance of any kind is the worst
sort of selfishness
those who truly fear god and keep his
commandments look upon these things in
the light of reason and religion
how can a man or woman keep the law of
god of divinity which requires a man to
love his neighbor as himself and yet
indulge in temperament appetite which
benumbs the brain weakens the intellect
and fills the body with disease
intemperance inflames the passions and
gives loose rain to lust
and reason and conscience are blinded by
the lower passions
wow you can really see that you ever see
someone or a group of people argue over
the last piece of broccoli
but what about if it's a chicken wing
right right oh you're right it's a whole
thing or like you know the church line
as you were saying like praying over the
red 40 but even saying a prayer after
arguing in the line because you want
such such a food and things like that
and it brings up these texts and
proverbs and psalms you know the the
lord is far from the wicked but he hears
the prayer of the righteous and if i
regard regard iniquity in my heart the
lord will not hear me and that goes from
the my new prayer to the biggest prayer
amen and it affects all areas of life so
just
this is just as important as any other
sin
amen
here's another statement from councils
on diets and foods page 150
satan is constantly on the alert to
bring the race fully under his control
his strongest hold his stronghold
on man is through appetite and this
satan seeks to stimulate in every
possible way
the artificial flavors the all the msg
all that stuff satan does everything he
can to
cause people to be intemperate because
if he can get them to yield to that sin
the other ones come easy
faithful in little things huh yes
now i want to show you a couple more as
we close
the bible says in first corinthians
chapter 6 verse 9 through 11
know ye not that the unrighteous shall
not inherit the kingdom of god
be not deceived that means by your
pastor by yourself
be not deceived
neither fornicators
nor
idolaters remember when we looked at
what fornication was and what it was
involved in food
neither fornicators nor idolaters nor
adulterers nor effeminate nor abusers of
themselves with mankind
nor thieves nor covetousness nor
drunkards
people will say
i don't drink alcohol let me tell you
something if you take a child you give
them a bowl full of crispy whatever
fruit loops or whatever and milk
my wife is a principal of a school she's
been in education in public education
for 20 years
she said eric i have almost all the
teachers in grades first through courage
four they all complain because the
children come in and they're crazy for
the first couple hours of school do you
know why because when you take sugar and
milk and you mix them in the human
stomach within a few hours they turn to
alcohol that's right
it says neither drunkards
nor revilers nor extortioners shall
inherit the kingdom of god
you can become drunk by overeating
or eating the wrong mixtures of food if
food sours in your stomach it becomes
like vinegar which is the next step to
alcohol
and then the bible gives us promise
and such were some of you i was that way
but now
you are washed
you are sanctified
you are justified in the name of our
lord jesus and by the spirit of our god
hallelujah so there's expectation for
change amen you're not just staying the
same there's not god not caring
amen he wants progression he wants
change amen
and this is that verse that we've
mentioned earlier every man that
striveth for the mastery is temperate in
all things
now they do it to obtain a corruptable
crown
but we are incorruptable
i therefore so run not as uncertainly
and i so fight not as one that beateth
or punches the air
but i keep my body under and i bring it
into subjection
lest by any means when i have preached
the glad tidings to other
i myself should be cast away that was
the apostle paul
christ
in behalf of the race
was to conquer appetite that's a key if
you want to overcome
that's the key
on behalf of the human race
he conquered appetite that's why that
temptation was faced
why he was faced with that
by enduring the most powerful test on
that point he went without food and
water for almost six weeks not one drop
of water for six weeks that's now how
would you answer that to say that that's
not humanly possible it's not humanly
possible
which means
god was in christ reconciling the world
unto himself
it's not humanly possible
but you know god never intended to leave
us as merely human
well that's human nature i'm only human
well don't stay that way
christ came to make us partakers of the
divine nature and divine nature is not
divine character it includes character
but it includes so much more
jesus had to go that long
because he felt my temptations to
appetite he felt your temptations and
your temptations and he felt those
temptations and he said i'm going to go
farther i'm going to go another day so
that i conquer this completely so that
everybody that believes on me and lets
me into their heart i my victory will be
theirs
it is not jesus's will that we should be
placed at a disadvantage in the conflict
with satan he would not have us
intimidated and discouraged by the
assaults of the serpent
be of good cheer he says i have overcome
the world
for me i was like
when i was wrestling with appetite i was
like
i got angry at god and i'm talking to
him because i was like
david did that i was like i know you
overcame but i'm not overcoming
so how does you overcoming help me
overcome and the lord was like
i'm standing at the door of your heart
if you'll open the door and i'm the word
of god jesus says
if you open the door to me the word of
god i will come
you and i've overcome and i've overcome
so if i come into you it's like oprah
winfrey well that spirit came into me
and i did this or denzel washington or
robin williams or keanu reeves when the
spirit came into me my thoughts changed
my strength changed my abilities changed
and jesus says if i come into you my
thoughts will be your thoughts my
strength will be your strength my faith
will be your strength my victory becomes
your victory
hallelujah let him or her who is
struggling against the power of appetite
look to the savior remember what jesus
said look unto me and be ye saved look
and live
look to the savior in the wilderness of
temptation
see him in his agony upon the cross as
he exclaimed i thirst
he has endured all that it is possible
for us to bear and his victory is
ours
jesus rested upon the wisdom and
strength of his heavenly father
he declares the lord god will help me
that's how he overcame when he was faced
with temptation he said yeah but thus
saith the lord
the lord god will help me thus saith the
lord i shall not live by bread alone but
by every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of god
therefore shall i not be confounded and
i know that i shall not be put to shame
behold the lord god will help me jesus
said
pointing to his own example jesus says
to each of us
who is among you that feareth the lord
that walketh in darkness and hath no
light
let him trust in the name of the lord
and stay upon his god amen amen
powerful
man amen well eric what a what a
blessing man
and you know this is not an easy topic
to bring up that you know there's a few
things that you you you just have to be
very careful
talking about people's plate don't touch
their plate you know
you know what's good though we're not
talking about it god's talking about it
that's what i really appreciated about
this is you know you brought it to the
bible you and you and you really showed
that you know this has been a struggle
in a lot of different people's lives
throughout the history of the bible old
testament new testament and i believe
the same is for us today and so thank
you for for bringing some clarity on
this topic i'm sure there is definitely
some
food for thought i don't mean that by
just a pun but um we hope you guys were
blessed by today's show and you got to
check out the next show we're going to
do with eric because we're going to get
to the science
a little bit the science and the sorcery
behind appetite what makes it have such
a stronghold how is satan using the
chemicals in the human body
to get us
so thank you for stopping by i'm
very curious of your comments please
leave them below and uh we just thank
you guys for checking out today's show
and eric wilson thank you for coming by
um if you want to check out more work
from eric his his ministry is isaiah
ministries and he's got his youtube page
we'll put a little link to his page as
well down there and uh eric's traveled
around and spoken internationally for a
while on a lot of these topics so check
out his ministry he's got a lot of great
material and uh we hope that you were
blessed by today's show like this if you
like it give it two thumbs up if you
want to share it please do share it and
we just thank you guys that have prayed
for this ministry supported this
ministry donated to this ministry you've
literally kept our lights on so that we
can go around and share the light with
others thank you and god bless amen
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world
and in 1999 a movie titled the matrix
hit the world stage these stories are
often told and seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
you